well we'll see if we can bring their
puzzles up to what was promised to
Scotland at what faisal described as the
last febrile days of the referendum
campaign when the unionist party is
fought they were losing and the three
amigos the three Westminster leaders
rushed up to Scotland and delivered the
vow when we promised us Home Rule D vote
to the max near federalism that was then
watered down by the Smith Commission and
now it's been watered down followed by
David Cameron so I suspect their
proposals today will be down like a a
lead balloon in Scotland but will you be
using our parliamentary influence to
make sure that Scotland gets delivered
to us what we were promised and that is
Home Rule near federalism and Divo to
the max well some might say that Barry
in mind their independence the yes
campaign lost that these are quite
generous proposals which do give extra
pass to Scotland
yes but Adam the of nought can I just
I'm quoting exactly the articulation of
Gordon Brown and and indeed the Liberals
during the referendum campaign what they
said if Scotland was going to get near
federalism Divo to the max that's
maximum devolution of financial power a
and Home Rule these proposals go nothing
close to that and nobody seriously could
articulate that they do they leave
seventy percent of taxation power in the
hands of Westminster and eighty percent
of welfare Paris that's not home loo
it's certainly not near federalism so
will use the influence that we look like
we're likely to get at Westminster to
enforce the vow that was made to the
Scottish people the real commitment the
real promise that was made during the
referendum campaign we intend to see it
delivered do you think these taxation
powers are going to be academic anyway
after all he didn't use the powers that
you did have when you were first
minister well the the powers that we had
the variation power was very badly drawn
for a whole range of technical reasons
no sane person would have tried to use
it and these parallels are are also
flawed over income tax you can't really
control income tax unless you control
the tax base and these powers give us no
control at all over the base of the
taxation system it's a fundamental and
fairly elementary point which is why
incidently
joslyn's attempt to say well we'll stop
Scottish MPs voting on income tax a big
bike partially live or being a little
better fit is quite ridiculous and
incredible if the husband doesn't want
Scottish MPs
to vote on income tax or other matters
which affect Scotland then he should do
a vault faster and agree with Scottish
independence will be glad to agree our
own taxation system and leave him to his
own devices in the mean time then of
course we'll use our influence to defend
Scottish interests and it looks like
that influence is going to be very
substantial indeed item do you think
that the broadcaster's on their second
attempt have got it right now with these
debate proposals including the SNP well
I think it's a great improvement from
the from the BBC and there and ITN we
have nicely Bickler hasn't the Nicola
Sturgeon hasn't received the proposals
yet as I understand it but I'm hoping
that sky will be doing something
revolutionary like being fair hey Adam
them in presumably we're going to get
some sort of indication from Sky Lee
you're not going to have this old steel
format of of to have two leaders
debating when everybody else is
recognizing that politics is much much
more interesting these days I hope the
sky will be putting forward proposals to
try and reflect the reality of modern
politics I mean the to read debates
quite good in terms of former but look
at the cast you've got for goodness sake
Adam it's the same old nonsense that
comes up everywhere Daan's their Prime
Minister's Questions whoever wants to
watch that when they can watch something
far more interesting with Nicola
Sturgeon and Leanne wood and people like
that in the debate well you say Nicola
Sturgeon but you're the one who's
running for Westminster are you sure
that she would represent the SP and both
of the proposed debates wouldn't you
want to get in there as well no I think
it's right and proper that the party
leader represents the party in these
debates people are voting for our
political party and Nicola Sturgeon will
certainly be I will debate early on
would for quite calmly and Natalie
Bennett for the the Green Party is
understanding how the fleshing it will
be to have these free
exciting regulus woman debating with
some pretty mediocre men who be in the
opposition I think that'll be a breath
of fresh air for the television debates
what a pity that sky as yet are missing
out on that opportunity well the sky
channel for proposal as you say is
currently for a Cameron versus Miliband
debate thank you very much D for joining
us